i'm kurt davina reading for reviewer
kevin kenizevic
pikmin 3 is the latest wii u gem to be
dusted off and repurposed for switch
and like other deluxe offerings it
arrives on the hybrid console packed
together with all of its original dlc
in a smattering of new content making
this the definitive version of one of
nintendo's most
underrated titles although the new side
story missions are the biggest selling
point
pikmin 3 has actually received a fair
number of other tweaks
in its move to switch as well there are
new difficulty options a hidden system
that helpfully nudges wayward players in
the right direction
and other additions like badges which
are unlockable achievements that are
doled out upon completing specific tasks
or reaching certain milestones these
nips and tucks don't radically alter the
experience of returning players
but they do help make the game more
inviting for newcomers
especially those who may not already be
familiar with the series
even without any dramatic touch-ups
pikmin 3 remains just as delightful
now as when it first premiered more than
seven years ago
thanks to its wonderfully idiosyncratic
blend of strategy
and adventure the centerpiece of the
package is the story mode which begins
just as previous games did with a crash
landing the ensuing adventure follows
the same rhythm as previous pikmin games
you land on the surface of the planet at
the start of each day and spend the next
15 or so minutes retrieving treasures
from the surrounding areas shepherding
your pikmin back to base before the sun
sets
and the crew returns to the safety of
orbit the space farers you command in
pikmin 3 are largely helpless on their
own
to accomplish any task you'll need to
rely on your pikmin
and it's here the game's strategy
elements reveal themselves
like its predecessors pikmin 3 is a game
fundamentally about
unit management you need to build up an
army of pikmin and use their abilities
to achieve your goals
each strain of pikmin boasts its own
unique attributes making them suited for
certain situations
red pikmin for instance are resistant to
fire and fierce fighters
while rock pikmin one of the two breeds
introduced in pikmin 3 are sturdier and
capable of shattering crystals
despite ostensibly being plant creatures
the pikmin are more akin to ants
one alone is helpless in the face of the
planet's wildlife but in sufficient
numbers
they'll be able to vanquish predators
many times their size
clear environmental obstacles and haul
fruit and other treasures back to camp
although the general framework of the
series remains unchanged pikmin 3 finds
a comfortable middle ground between the
hurried tension of the original pikmin
and the more leisurely pace of its
sequel just as in the first title
you cannot explore the planet
indefinitely in pikmin 3.
the length of your journey is dictated
by your food supply
the crew consumes a bottle of juice at
the end of each day so you'll need to
have at least
one ration on hand at all times to
continue your expedition
fortunately fruit is plentiful you'll
find oversized strawberries plums and
other delectables scattered around all
corners of the planet and
each piece you retrieve will be turned
into juice making it easy to build up an
ample supply and buy yourself more than
enough time to explore
some of these fruits will be waiting in
plain sight but most will require
a bit of finagling to reach which is
where the joy of pikmin 3's gameplay
systems is most potently felt
retrieving the fruit will require you to
negotiate the environment using the
abilities at your disposal with more
areas opening up as you discover new
types of pikmin there's an almost
metroid-like sense of progression to the
adventure you'll spot
say a piece of fruit or a breakable gate
just out of reach beyond a river in one
of the early levels
encouraging you to return later on after
you've acquired the minions to access it
there's a practical drive to explore too
as you work your way across levels
you'll discover and create shortcuts
that offer a more efficient route back
to your base
making exploration constantly rewarding
the challenge and joy of the game comes
from plotting out your objectives and
utilizing the pikmin
to best effect multitasking is of the
essence in pikmin 3.
particularly after you reunite the
entire crew and gain the ability to
switch between
all three explorers on the fly the sense
of accomplishment you feel when you
divide up your troops and retrieve
multiple pieces of fruit from different
corners of the map within a single day
is immensely satisfying this emphasis on
multitasking also makes the newly added
ability to play story mode cooperatively
a delight as you can divide up and
accomplish tasks much more efficiently
with a second player controlling one of
the other captains
though like pikmin 3's other modes this
is restricted to local play
limiting its usefulness although the
adventure isn't particularly arduous
even on the hard difficulty your
fondness for the pikmin themselves
will add extra weight to your decisions
it's hard not to grow attached to the
little critters when you see the
adorable way they scurry behind you and
squeak as they
hoist a fruit or fallen enemy and it
feels genuinely gutting when one
perishes out of your own negligence
[Music]
you'll wince with guilt when a pikmin is
gobbled up by a monster or left behind
at the end of the day
due to your carelessness and the game
reminds you of your losses by keeping a
running tally of all the pikmin that
have fallen over the course of your
journey
of course sometimes losses are
inevitable and the game gives you the
opportunity
to replay a day should things not go as
well as you'd hoped
so no misstep is completely irrevocable
complementing story mode in pikmin 3
deluxe are new side story missions
starring olamar and louis
these have the duo retrieving treasure
to once again financially bail out their
employer
and they're enjoyable but ultimately a
little underwhelming
unlike in the main story each of these
missions is self-contained and starts
you off with a set amount
and types of pikmin that makes them much
more about efficiency
than exploration as you're only given a
limited amount of time and resources to
accomplish your task
this offers a different kind of appeal
than the main adventure and it feels
genuinely satisfying to clear a map with
a couple of minutes to spare through
efficient multitasking
on the whole however these missions lack
the exploratory hooks
that make the story mode so compelling
and they aren't quite as appealing as a
result the same can be said of mission
mode in general which offers three
different types of smaller
self-contained challenges to complete
ranging from defeating bosses as quickly
as possible to retrieving all the
treasure in a level they're a fun way to
extend the game's longevity but they
feel ancillary to the adventure proper
bingo battle likewise is great fun if
you have someone around to enjoy it with
turning the usual pikmin gameplay into a
head-to-head race to collect specific
treasures these contests quickly become
hectic as you contend
with not only roaming predators but
enemy pikmin as well
further illustrating how well pikmin's
core mechanics lend themselves to
different types of play
however the lack of any online support
hampers the mode's appeal
bingo battle requires a second player so
if you don't have someone around to
enjoy it with
you're out of luck although pikmin 3
deluxe may not offer much in the way of
substantial new content
the game still holds up wonderfully
thanks to its unique gameplay and
carefully constructed levels
and the tweaks and additions that have
been implemented here help smooth
over the whole package for newer players
even three installments in there is no
other series quite like pikmin
which helps pikmin 3 still feel fresh 7
years after its original release
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is